we begin with dr retroward doctor thank
you very much it's great to have you
with us today um you know i spoke with
dr francis collins last week
of uh the nih the head of the nih um he
sort of scoffed at the notion
that there might have been a nefarious
uh
you know purpose of the development of
this virus
but you know when you look into this
report that came out in the wall street
journal this weekend
by dr steven quay and richard muller
they really sort of take apart the
composition of this virus and they
argue that there's a lot of signs in the
genome of the virus
that it very well may have come from the
lab
so i think what we know martha is that
after 81 000 samples in nature there was
no virus within decades of evolution of
covid19
we know the wuhan lab did research on
bat coronaviruses
specifically how they could attack uh
human receptors like the ace2 receptor
in lungs
and yes there was military involvement
at that lab so
the evidence is still circumstantial but
it's becoming
really truly compelling that this was at
least a lab leak it might have been a
virus that they collected but more
likely it was a virus that they made
directly in some way so i want to ask
you about that because
i'm hearing that a lot in people who
were very close to the studying the
situation
they're saying well it was not an
intentional it was most likely
an inadvertent leak what evidence points
to that
that conclusion so
there's no evidence that points to it
being an inadvertent leak but it makes
sense that it would be what the evidence
really does point to however is that the
virus was likely generated in the lab
that could be done by natural ways by
passing it to make it more infectious
or by direct genetic manipulation
and that's what we're really honing in
on now i think everyone believes it was
an accident because
accidental leaks do occur i haven't seen
any evidence that it would have been a
purposeful leak
but you know you can't discount anything
okay i mean that that's important
what about this news it was in the
financial times today
that there are at least 59 maximum
biosafety level four that's the name of
these sorts of labs that are planned
around
the world and several of them are in
china why are we seeing the expansion of
the kind of labs that do this work and
does that concern you as someone who has
studied
bio-weapons warfare it does really
concern me
we all want more research to be done in
a defensive way
but it concerns me for two reasons
number one is that lab accidents do
occur
and frequently even these bsl4 labs
operate at much
lower safety levels like we saw in muhan
secondly
there is a lot of dual function research
and
whether we like it or not and whether we
would like to admit it
there are offensive biological weapons
programs around the world
and you know the kind of actors that do
that so this could easily be used for
those nefarious circumstances and we
need to be
very careful and watchful would you say
are you now surprised when you look back
that there were
any u.s dollars going to the wuhan lab
to do any kind of collaborative research
um i'm not surprised because the nih
funds so many things what i'm really
surprised about is that there weren't
more controls
and more accountability to be able to
interview people in the lab to
understand what they were doing that
just didn't exist and
we really need a reboot of our research
process for foreign investments
well we know this dr xi jiang li uh
she's called the bat lady
and she does a lot of the research at
the wuhan lab and she wears like a
complete
biohazmat suit when she does her work
in that lab she is certainly on the list
of people that
investigators would love to speak to
about what happened in there doctor
thank you it's always good to have you
with us
thank you dr shaw